I'm like freaking out so much I'm only
worried in that I don't think there's
any of that I have not I'm expecting
hopefully to learn something new about
Cody I'm wondering if I'm gonna find out
something very surprising we're both
pretty honest so I don't think there
will be too many surprises not a lot of
skeletons in any closet never have I
ever said I love you without meaning it
may have told white lies enjoy hat I
think it was just someone I was having
sex with and they said it was a turn-on
for them and it was like sure let's try
it out the nose man I say what I mean
and I mean what I say have you ever
fantasized about a friend's significant
other I would definitely say that there
were like certainly times in like high
school and otherwise we'd just be like
man that'd be cool wouldn't it have you
ever shoplifted I'm a drag queen I was
looking for a new bald cap to go
underneath my wig and I found that the
bottoms of like pantyhose or tights work
really well aren't those cheap anyway
though yeah that's why I'm bad at it you
know what i shoplift when I was like 3
years old never have I ever forgotten
someone's name I've slept with good for
you it was like a one-night stand sort
of deal and I didn't want them to forget
my name the next day I don't know so I
was very adamant about making sure they
remembered my name
but in doing so I completely ignored
whatever their name was have you ever
cheated on my partner
that's actually how we ended up together
have you ever faked an orgasm in general
what do you mean in general I have not
huh I have faked an orgasm before but it
was only because I orgasm too early
never have I ever taken someone's
virginity really have you ever been to a
strip club this actually we haven't
talked about but I have not I have not
either I was ready for you to say yes
never have I ever had a threesome we
have had a threesome with each other
have you ever stolen something from your
partner oh the heart the fake I love you
was most surprising I was not surprised
sorry
yeah what - nope we go we like talk so
much and we're super illness which is
great something I learned about Alex is
you're just bad at stealing
[Music]